die befürworter und gegner von
erneuerbaren energien haben sich
heutzutage zahlreiche argumente um die
ohren aber wie wird es denn jetzt
wirklich aussehen mit unserer
stromversorgung im jahr 2045 eine finale
antwort darauf kann natürlich noch
keiner geben doch ein deutsches
forschungsteam hat es zumindest versucht
wir haben uns angesehen woran die
sogenannten kopernikus projekte arbeiten
und wie sie sich unser energiesystem in
23 jahren vorstellen der nebel in der
glaskugel namens energiewende lichtet
sich langsam
bei der energiewende seien inzwischen
viele staaten an dem einstigen vorreiter
deutschland vorbeigezogen wir brauchen
den neustart gebrauchen der energie
werden die 2.0 es ist dringend notwendig
dass
wir momentan tun können ist die bahn zu
ebnen entlang der wir die nächsten 20
jahre geben müssen um diese
klimakatastrophe zu verhindern haben
[Applaus]
also ihr habt es alle mitbekommen das
klima wandelt sich und das nicht zum
besseren einen großen anteil hat dabei
die energieerzeugung da alles was wir
zur energieerzeugung verbrennen also
erdöl erdgas und co einen enormen co2
ausstoßes verursacht müssen wir aufhören
solche rohstoffe zu nutzen
deutschland zählt auf klimaneutralität
bis zum jahr 2045 die eu bis spätestens
2050 wenn das klappen soll muss sich
unsere energieversorgung also
schnellstmöglich
grundlegend verändern was uns zu den
erneuerbaren energien bringt hier müssen
wir erst einmal ein paar sachen klären
bevor wir unsere zeitreise ins jahr 2045
starten können also wie war das noch mal
war die energiewende jetzt machbar oder
nicht die debatte darum wird seit
jahrzehnten geführt und langsam
kristallisieren sich ein paar antworten
heraus darüber könnten wir jetzt
eigentlich locker einen 45 minuten video
machen und ja warum eigentlich nicht ist
ja immerhin eines der wichtigsten themen
unserer zeit wenn ihr daran interesse
hätte dann schreibt uns das gerne mal in
die kommentare für dieses video hier
müssen wir es aber etwas reduzieren so
viel zeit haben wir leider gerade nicht
daher vorhang auf für eines der
komplexesten vorhaben des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts erklärt
in nur 5 minuten
[Musik]
erst einmal ist wichtig wenn wir hier
von energie sprechen geht es nicht nur
um strom grundsätzlich lässt sich der
einsatz von energie in vier bereiche
unterteilen die stromerzeugung der
verkehr die gebäude also insbesondere
das heizen und die industrie hier in
diesem video geht es vor allem um strom
die industrie und ein bisschen um den
verkehr beim punkt stromerzeugung
konnten wir in deutschland bereits gute
fortschritte in richtung
klimaneutralität machen auch weil das
ersetzen von fossil erzeugtem strom
durch strom aus solarzellen und
windrädern etwas einfacher umsetzbar ist
bei den anderen drei bereichen verkehr
gebäude und industrie gab es in den
letzten jahren aber leider weniger
fortschritte doch ist eine so krasse
umstellung des gesamten energiesystems
überhaupt möglich nun tatsächlich ja die
mehrheit der akteurinnen und akteure ist
sich mittlerweile sicher dass eine
umstellung des energiesystems auf
erneuerbare energien technisch möglich
ist so das muss auch einfach mal gesagt
werden quellen zu unseren aussagen
findet ihr wie immer ganz transparent
unten in der video beschreibung genug
strom produzieren könnten wir ohnehin
laut berechnungen des fraunhofer
instituts für solare energiesysteme
wären wir flächenmäßig und rein
rechnerisch alleine mit photovoltaik in
der lage ein vielfaches unseres
strombedarfs zu produzieren mittlerweile
gehen die meisten expertinnen und
experten davon aus dass eine
energiewende auch möglich ist ohne dass
strom auf lange sicht viel teurer wird
doch klar eine solche umstellung ist
nicht einfach über nacht gemacht denn
unser energiesystem war bisher nicht für
erneuerbare energien ausgelegt zum einen
nutzen wir aktuell nur einen teil
unserer energie als strom in unser auto
kommt zb benzin in unsere gasheizung
erdgas und die industrie verbindet auch
häufig erdgas und auch erdöl bei solar
und windanlagen kommt aber erst mal nur
strom bei raus das heißt wir müssen ganz
viele verfahren auf strom umstellen denn
denen können wir auf dauer erneuerbar
herstellen zum anderen müssen wir in
unserem aktuellen stromnetz immer in
etwa soviel strom erzeugen wie wir
gerade verbrauchen sowohl zu viel als
auch zu wenig produktion kann das netz
zum kollabieren bringen das ist dieses
berühmte horrorszenario der dunkel
flaute oder des blackouts von dem
erneuerbare energien gegner gerne
sprechen wenn ihr mehr zum gleichgewicht
im stromnetz wissen wollt dann schaut
euch gerne mal die dieses video hier von
mir an da erkläre ich das ganze noch mal
ausführlich okay wir müssen also unsere
stromversorgung und unser stromnetz neu
denken das scheint jetzt erst mal wie
ein riesiges unlösbares problem ist es
aber nicht konkret kann man diese mammut
herausforderung in drei bereiche
einteilen erstens der wind weht nicht
die ganze zeit ebenso wenig wie die
sonne nicht die ganze zeit scheint das
heißt wir können nicht steuern wann wir
wie viel strom bekommen damit das
stromnetz nicht kollabiert brauchen wir
ein neues viel flexibleres stromsystem
und das so schnell wie möglich in
deutschland gibt es bereits jetzt einige
regionen in denen mehr strom aus
erneuerbaren energien produziert wird
als das aktuelle stromnetz in der region
aufnehmen kann dass wir nicht
kontrollieren können wann wir wie viel
sonne und dementsprechend strom zur
verfügung haben führt auch zur
herausforderungen nummer zwei wir
brauchen viel mehr strom als wir
brauchen oder auch wir müssen
theoretisch viel mehr produzieren können
als wir normalerweise verbrauchen es
klingt paradox ist aber logisch sagen
wir mal wir bauen so viele solar und
windanlagen dass sie bei voller
auslastung genauso viel energie
produzieren wie wir maximal brauchen
jetzt weht der wind aber zum beispiel
nur ein drittel so toll wie er könnte
und die sonne scheint auch nicht das
heißt wir müssen das dreifache von dem
was wir brauchen theoretisch produzieren
können damit wir auch an tagen mit nur
einem drittel wind genug energie haben
hinzu kommt dass wir auch absolut
gesehen in zukunft viel mehr strom
brauchen werden wenn auch unsere
industrie unsere autos und unsere
heizungen mit strom funktionieren sollen
schätzungen gehen davon aus dass wir
etwa doppelt so viel strom brauchen
werden wie viel genau kann aber keiner
sagen weil noch so viele details
ungeklärt sind man weiß auch noch nicht
genau wie viel strom wird durch mehr
effizienz und klimaschutz maßnahmen
wiederum einsparen werden auf der
anderen seite wird auf jeden fall
wesentlich weniger gas und erdöl
verbraucht wodurch auch der
primärenergieverbrauch geringer wird
aber insgesamt heißt dass trotzdem wir
brauchen verdammt viele windparks und
solaranlagen
[Musik]
was uns zur herausforderung nummer 3
führt die infrastruktur und der
widerstand aus der bevölkerung wo und
wie das alles hin am besten bauen wir
den ganzen norden voll mit windparks da
wo viel wind weht doch dann brauchen wir
auch die infrastruktur um den strom nach
bayern und baden württemberg zu bekommen
dafür muss das stromnetz ausgebaut
werden und diese stromtrassen wollen die
viele menschen nicht gerade in ihren
vorgarten stehen haben genauso wenig wie
die windräder selbst klagen von
bürgerinnen und bürgern und vor allem
aufwendige genehmigungsverfahren
gesperrte bauflächen und
naturschutzgründen gehören unter anderem
zu den faktoren die den ausbau der
windenergie gerade verlangsamen salopp
ausgedrückt wir brauchen viel mehr
infrastruktur und dafür brauchen wir
viel fläche aber keiner will sie
hergeben und stoppt habe ich geschafft
ok lassen wir das mal zusammen wir
brauchen also viele anlagen für
erneuerbare energien mehr infrastruktur
ein flexibleres stromnetz und
zwischenspeicher für schlechte zeiten
außerdem mehr mitarbeit der bürgerinnen
und bürger und schnellere
genehmigungsverfahren der behörden
okay die forschung arbeitet mit
hochdruck daran für diese
herausforderungen lösungen zu finden und
wie unser blick auf unser energiesystem
im jahr 2045 gleich zeigen wird bekommen
wir ziemlich im erfolg eine dieser
forschungsinitiativen sind die
kopernikus projekte sie werden vom
bundesministerium für bildung und
forschung gefördert und versuchen oft
genau diese fragen antworten zu finden
und sie unterstützen uns bei diesem
video hier das bedeutet aber nicht dass
es nicht auch noch viele andere
forschungsprojekte da draußen gibt die
sich alle mit diesen fragen
auseinandersetzen für die drei großen
herausforderungen haben die kopernikus
projekte folgende ideen am ersten
problem dass es nicht immer gleich viel
wind und sonne gibt arbeitet das projekt
so nett
[Musik]
die grundidee ist simpel wir nutzen den
strom wenn er da ist und wir verbrauchen
weniger wenn er nicht da ist okay das
heißt den morgendlichen kaffee gibt es
erst wenn der wind weder was natürlich
nicht aber wann die wäsche wäscht oder
das elektroauto lädt ist ja eigentlich
nicht so wichtig oder solange alles
fertig ist wenn ich morgens aufstehe die
tu dresden arbeitet zum beispiel daran
für häuser genauso eine intelligente
stromverteilung zu entwickeln das
projekt so energie beschäftigt sich
speziell mit solchen sogenannten
ausgleichs potenzialen in der industrie
denn die industrie alleine verbraucht
bereits rund 45 prozent des stroms in
deutschland
als ersten schritt haben sich die
forschenden also angesehen welche
prozesse die waschmaschinen und
elektroautos in der industrie sind also
bei welchen energieintensiven prozessen
es nicht so wichtig ist wann genau sie
stattfinden oder welche prozesse durch
andere einstellungen oder energieträger
ihren strombedarf verändern können in
einem zweiten schritt haben sie eine
intelligente steuerung programmiert sie
analysiert automatisch ob es gerade zu
viel oder zu wenig strom in deutschland
gibt und welches unternehmen gerade in
diesem moment ausgleichen kann die
steuerung kann den unternehmen dabei
helfen ihren stromverbrauch anzupassen
und das stromnetz zu unterstützen in der
energie flexiblen modell region augsburg
wird genau dieses system gerade getestet
ein dritter schritt versucht gerade
anreize für die unternehmen zu schaffen
denn derzeit ist es für die unternehmen
häufig noch teurer energie flexibel zu
arbeiten und das war natürlich nicht so
sein und auch das versucht sie energie
zu ändern das klingt alles nach
zukunftsmusik nun ja ist es auch aber an
einigen orten ist diese zukunftsmusik
schon jetzt wirklichkeit das zeigt zum
beispiel das unternehmen alois müller es
betreibt aktuell eine fabrik die energie
flexibel ist und ein smartes energienetz
hat so stellt das unternehmen zum
beispiel immer dann den sehr
energieintensiven stickstoff ja wenn die
solarzellen auf dem dach viel strom
produzieren das funktioniert weil diese
maschine nicht rund um die uhr laufen
müssen so können unterm strich zwei
drittel des energieverbrauchs von der
eigenen photovoltaikanlage gedeckt
werden und es gibt noch ein zweites
projekt von kopernikus das an lösungen
für die herausforderungen im raw 1
arbeitet also daran dass wir nur
begrenzt beeinflussen können wann wir
wie viel strom zur verfügung haben denn
neben einem flexiblen verbrauch könnte
man den überschüssigen strom einfach
speichern
wobei das mit dem einfach so eine sache
ist mit kurzfristigen speichern zum
beispiel batterien können wir
überschüssige energie für ein paar
stunden aufbewahren also zum beispiel
die sonnenenergie aus den mittagsstunden
für die glühbirne am abend mit
saisonalen speichern wiederum können wir
die herbststürme für die zeiten
speichern in denen zum beispiel nur ein
warmes sommer lüftchen weht
[Musik]
für diese längere zeiträume könnte eine
box technologie zum einsatz kommen
hierbei wird überschüssiger strom in gas
wasserstoff oder ähnliches umgewandelt
das besser und in größeren mengen
gelagert werden kann anders als früher
gedacht soll dieser prozess
kontinuierlich stattfinden nicht mehr
nur noch mit überschussstrom das
forschungsprojekt p 2x experimentiert
gerade mit der herstellung von solchen
stoffen wie genau das funktioniert könnt
ihr euch in diesem video hier von mir am
beispiel von evs ansehen da war ich vor
ort und habe mir eine anlage angeschaut
die co2 aus der luft sorgt und daraus
klimaneutrale kraftstoffe herstellt
übrigens mit diesem power to fix
verfahren können wir noch viel mehr als
nur energiespeicher produzieren das
verfahren kann auch die grundstoffe für
zum beispiel kunststoffen chemikalien
kosmetika und sogar düngemittel liefern
finde ich ehrlich gesagt ziemlich cool
alles so eine technologie wie power to
exist super wichtig um auch die bereiche
mit energie zu versorgen die nicht
direkt elektrifiziert werden können wie
zum beispiel der flug schiffs oder
schwerlastverkehr oder die chemie und
stahlindustrie mit power tricks können
neben energieträgern auch fossile
rohstoffe ersetzt werden co2 wird hier
quasi zum rohstoff die chemieindustrie
ist zum beispiel bislang auf öl und gas
als kohlenstoff fälle für chemikalien
angewiesen mit power to fix kann dieser
kohlenstoff stattdessen auf co2 gewonnen
werden ok kommen wir zur herausforderung
nummer zwei dass wir mehr strom brauchen
als wir brauchen eine banale lösung
dafür ist natürlich einfach mehr strom
dafür brauchen wir aber noch mehr wind-
und solaranlagen die ja jetzt schon
keiner im vorgarten haben möchte wie
viel platz dass brauchen würde ist
schwer zu beziffern laut einer studie
werden wir ein bis zwei prozent der
gesamten fläche der eu brauchen werden
wenn wir die eu komplett auf wind- und
solarenergie umstellen wollen also ein
halbes bis ein mal portugal ganz grob so
oder so stellt sich die frage wie kann
man den umbau der energieversorgung so
gestalten dass alle damit leben können
und genau dieser frage widmet sich das
kopernikus forschungsprojekt ariane
[Musik]
welche politischen instrumente können
sicherstellen dass die klimaziele
erreicht werden und in einem zweiten
schritt wie würde die bevölkerung auf
solche instrumente reagieren ein
beispiel für die forschung in ariadne
ist eine studie die untersucht was
konkret notwendig ist um die
klimaneutralität zu erreichen also wie
zum beispiel durch förderung und
einfachere ausschreibungsverfahren mehr
photovoltaikanlagen und windanlagen
gebaut werden können vor kurzem haben
sich die forschenden außerdem mit
bürgerinnen und bürgern aus ganz
deutschland getroffen und haben mit
ihnen diskutieren welche lösungen auch
für sie machbar wären diese studie und
mehr zu den bürger austausch findet ihr
genau wie alle anderen quellen dieses
videos unten in der video beschreibung
direkt unter dem like-button
bleibt also noch herausforderungen
nummer drei dass wir die infrastruktur
unseres stromnetzes ausbauen müssen denn
irgendwie muss ja beispielsweise der
windstrom vom norden im großen stil in
den süden transportiert werden wir
brauchen also mehr leitungen und wir
brauchen leitungen die strom in zwei
richtungen transportieren können das ist
neu denn bisher floss strom meistens nur
vom kraftwerk zum verbraucher
mittlerweile speist aber auch der
verbraucher zb mit seiner solaranlage
auf dem dach wieder strom zurück ins
system das alles muss gemanagt und
überwacht werden die stromnetze müssen
wahnsinnig flexibel werden manche
forschende denken dass das stromnetz der
zukunft in kleineren netzen organisiert
sein sollte in diesem sogenannten
zellularen ansatz werden auf lokaler
ebene quasi energie zellen gebildet
innerhalb von denen soll der
energiehaushalt plan und steuerbar sein
diese zellen werden dann durch
energienetze und kommunikationssysteme
untereinander verbunden und bilden
übergeordnete größere energiezellen und
so weiter die hoffnung ist dass weniger
netzausbau notwendig ist je besser
stromangebot und nachfrage innerhalb der
energiezellen austariert werden können
wenn stromproduktion und verbrauch
innerhalb einer zelle jedoch häufiger
nicht glatt aufgehen könnte dieser
zellulare ansatz auch neue probleme
erschaffen dann braucht man nämlich mehr
möglichkeiten die stromschwankungen in
jedem einzelnen dieser teilnetze
auszugleichen und das bedeutet
wahrscheinlich mehr batterien und smarte
zell vernetzung außerdem braucht so ein
netz eine neue erstmal teure
infrastruktur und löst nicht das problem
das windenergie zb vor allem im norden
gibt der süden dieser aber auch braucht
eine andere idee für eine veränderung im
stromnetz ist ein europaweit es so
genanntes overlay märz also ein netz auf
dem stromnetz mit ihm könnte man im
großen stil schwankungen ausgleichen und
dafür sorgen dass jedes eu-land weniger
ausgleichs einheiten wie zum beispiel
batterien bauen muss außerdem könnte
spanien so zb von unserem nordseewind
profitieren während wir etwas von deren
sonne ab haben könnten aber ein
zelluläres energiesystem und ein
europaweites netz müssen sich ja nicht
per se ausschließen vielleicht liegt die
antwort ja sogar irgendwo in der mitte
in beiden fällen brauchen wir stromnetze
die sehr flexibel reagieren können wie
will man das möglich machen an dieser
frage sitzt ich könnte es euch bereits
denken auch ein forschungsprojekt aus
dem kopernikus verbund es heißt and
schuhe und untersuchte wie netze
miteinander agieren können
[Musik]
mittels selbstlernender künstliche
intelligenz sollen die stromnetze der
zukunft flexibler und sicherer werden
ein beispiel ein schuh testet gerade ein
sicherheitssystem einen sogenannten
adaptiv schutz mit dem das stromnetz
digital überwacht und analysiert wird
solche systeme schalten normalerweise
bei einer störung den strom automatisch
in sekundenbruchteilen ab doch die neuen
systeme können flexibler auf die
schwankenden strommengen reagieren denn
sie lernen mit hilfe von ki ständig dazu
so können zb energieströme bei bedarf
umgelenkt werden um eine überlastung zu
verhindern der einbau der innovativen
geräte in einer testregion ist bereits
im juli 2021 gestartet
okay das war jetzt ganz schön viel
forschung und es könnte so sein wenn
deswegen möchte ich an dieser stelle mal
mit euch ein gedanken experiment wagen
stellen wir uns vor wir sind im jahr
2045 die energiewende ist erfolgreich
abgelaufen und unser energiesystem ist
auf erneuerbare energien umgestellt
wie sähe das jetzt konkret aus die
kopernikus projekte stellen sich das
land dann so vor
2045 decken privathaushalte und
industrie ihren strombedarf mit hilfe
von erneuerbaren strom wenn das
stromangebot schwankt dann gleich ein
heim speicher unternehmen batterien und
patricks technologien sie auch das
intelligente netz reguliert die
umverteilung automatisch die industrie
kann mit hilfe von tricks produkten
erdgas öl und kohle ersetzen der
autoverkehr ist vor allem elektrisch der
güterverkehr auch schwerlast und
flugverkehr funktioniert mit
klimaneutralen evels aus power tricks
verfahren
ist das nicht eine wunderschöne zukunft
wichtig ist natürlich auch die
kopernikus projekte können nur prognosen
machen selbstverständlich extrem
fundierte prognosen von expertinnen und
experten die diese anhand von plausiblen
szenarien entwickelt haben aber eben nur
prognosen wie unsere welt 2045 wirklich
aussehen wird werden wir erst in 23
jahren sehen wer weiß vielleicht machen
wir dann ja ein kleines video hierzu
oder einen hattrick reagiert auf 23
jahre altes video abonniert auf jeden
fall den kanal damit eure kinder das
nicht verpassen an dieser stelle einen
riesigen dank an die kopernikus projekte
die uns bei diesem video hier mit der
extrem aufwändigen recherche unterstützt
haben und wie gesagt schreibt uns gerne
mal in die kommentare wenn ihr einen
wirklich ausführliches video zu
erneuerbaren energien haben wollen also
wirklich alles drin alle mythen alle
themen dazu 45 minuten vielleicht so
ungefähr in der länge wie das e-auto
video das hier war auf jeden fall nicht
nur ein ganz kurz andres dieses super
spannenden und mega wichtigen themas bis
dahin bleibt neugierig patrick